do you think there's
any use for this information so for more
like for lack of a better term for more
agreeable men
more agreeable men i assume are going to
have a harder time attracting women
because women are more attracted to
these dark triad traits is there a way
for people to kind of present themselves
in a manner that embodies these traits
without actually being
a terrible person
you know it's funny i have a a good
friend of mine here at cambridge um he's
a criminologist vincent harrenham he has
coined this idea of the dark
i think he calls it the dark gentleman
uh and i may be getting some of the
details wrong but it's essentially the
sort of this marriage between
a guy who's maybe a little bit edgy and
you know ambitious and
it can be maybe somewhat emotionally
distant but they know what they want
they're sort of using
um
you know using some of those those
qualities to pursue what they want while
also sort of having a soft side to them
you know the sort of uh whatever like
the dad versus the cad but sort of those
two things put together
um i suppose yeah i mean people can
cultivate
and
suppress various aspects of their nature
i mean broadly speaking in the
personality research our personalities
like the big five they tend to be pretty
stable throughout our lives you know if
you measure at age 18 compared to
you know 50 in your 50s or something the
correlation tends to be around point
eight i mean it's very stable
but that's sort of um
looking in the aggregate scale you know
across multiple many individuals across
time but as an individual person
you can sort of and i'm sure people have
experienced this where
um you may want to say be more
extroverted you know in a social
situation maybe you're more of an
introvert maybe you're more of a bookish
type
but you want to make friends or you want
to
get promoted or something so you you
sort of become more extroverted or
pretend to be that way and i think guys
can do this too with
with uh maybe being slightly more
disagreeable while you know retaining
some of the
the the good guy traits um speaking of
extroversion um this reminds me of some
interesting research on this too that um
generally speaking people are
they report being happier when they
behave in a more extroverted way
and this is not just true for people who
score high on extroversion but uh
introverts too
um if you uh tell introverts you know if
introverts are in a study and the
researchers say like you know go go
behave in a more social way interact
with more people talk to more people
today
um introduce yourself to more people
than you normally would something like
that um they actually report being
happier
than when they behave in an introverted
way when they sort of go against their
impulses you know maybe they want to
stay inside but they force themselves to
go out and i find this interesting too
that uh sometimes you know going against
your own personality uh impulses can can
actually increase uh your sense of
well-being
that's interesting i i have a theory
that okay so you know if you
if you're an extremely agreeable person
you you tend to value you tend to
you can potentially kind of cram down
whatever you're feeling
so that you don't hurt anybody's
feelings right oh i don't want to say
that because this person might interpret
it this way and if they feel sad i'm
going to feel sad because i'm an
agreeable person
i think that if people learn how to
overcome that and actually say how they
feel they feel better i think it might
just be harder for agreeable people
because they care more about other
people's feelings but that kind of thing
i think you can practice and you're like
okay you're concerned you're going to
say something it's going to hurt
somebody's feelings
but you should probably say it you have
that feeling in you if you just do that
and then you survey the outcome you're
like okay this wasn't as bad as i
thought it was going to be i think if
you practice that you can get over that
and i think
for men who are more prone to
being agreeable like that i think that's
probably a good thing to practice
in general but also to make you more
attracted to women
yeah yeah yeah i think there's there's
uh
i mean that's definitely i think a
useful way to do it and
and also i mean beyond
you know trying to
whatever like shape your personality
into different ways or behave
differently you can also just sort of
put yourself in places where people
might be more attracted to
a more agreeable man
um so if you you know
maybe maybe going out to uh i don't know
a nightclub or something is not the
ideal place if you're more of say an
agreeable or introverted kind of guy but
i don't know religious services or or
libraries or something like maybe
they're more you know women there might
be more more interested in a more
agreeable kind of person so definitely
you can sort of put yourself in the
right environment as well
um but yeah i mean i think the the
dating question is fascinating just
because i know
i think it's just it's just becoming
more difficult for a lot of young people
you know guys who are you know they have
good careers they have a good income all
those kinds of things and
they have some of them had to make it a
second job basically of like
reorganizing their lives in order to
find a suitable romantic partner i think
it's getting pretty pretty rough out
there
so what does that mean reorganizing
their lives
yeah so like a friend of mine for
example he
uh
you know sort of changed the hours he
worked at in order to go to cooking
classes because he just figured you know
he likes to cook and he wants to meet
you know a person who would want to cook
too
uh you know
sort of going to the gym at the right
hours
just sort of generally changing his
habits and introducing himself to more
people um getting his uh dating apps
like
he had like a lot of input from
different women and different people who
could help him like portray you know
convey himself in the way that that
would maximize his chances of finding a
suitable
uh partner
and i think a lot of guys you know
they're they don't do this you know they
just sort of go through life and wonder
what's going on
and other guys are realizing like oh it
really is something you have to take
seriously it's not something that's just
gonna happen by accident for you you and
i'm sure women are having in many ways
the same kind of experience but you know
you're speaking from you know most of my
friends to be guys and this is sort of
their experience and
yeah it really is um
you know they're spending hours a week
on on this uh on this project of how to
find a how to find a girlfriend
yeah okay well we could talk about that
but but first okay so this kind of has
to do with what you just said um
this is from your article as well
because of the increased risk women
carry they tend to be choosier about
their partners
in contrast men are less discerning
studies of online dating for example
find that most men find most women to be
at least somewhat attractive in contrast
women on average view 80 of men as below
average in attractiveness another study
found that on the dating app tinder men
liked more than 60 percent of the female
profiles they viewed while women liked
only four and a half percent of male
profiles so this might be a problem
that's
way more prevalent for men i didn't
realize that 80 percent of men is below
average
that's quite off
it is i mean right because you know you
would think like 50 right it's sort of
like 50 above and 50 below but to have
80 percent rated below is pretty you
know
it's pretty grim um
but this this sort of reflects our uh
innate evolutionary psychology you know
so a lot of evolutionary researchers
uh essentially find that you know
because men carry less risk for uh well
during sex right they're less likely
even if they have sex with someone uh
they're less likely to contract uh an
std
than women are i didn't know and yeah
yeah and so well i mean because men's
like organs are on the outside whereas
women's are on the inside and that sort
of affects you know uh likely to
contracting but then also of course
pregnancy itself
um is extremely burdensome and you can
imagine you know it's already burdensome
in the modern era but you can imagine um
you know 50 or 100 000 years ago in the
ancestral environment where humans
evolved you know like getting pregnant
for a woman was uh it was a
life-or-death uh experience in many many
cases so
um as a result of this women have
evolved to be much more selective about
who they have sex with um you know they
want a guy who sort of has you know good
good genetic quality but also a guy who
sort of
uh could take care of them and provide
for them and all those things whereas
for men the risk was so minuscule and
the potential gain of having a kid was
so high in evolutionary terms right in
terms of having more kids and so
um for this reason i i once had this
this line i i said this uh on our mutual
friend chris williamson's podcast um
yeah a couple years ago now which is
basically that for men the default when
they evaluate women the default is i
would probably sleep with her unless
there's some
extraordinary reason why i shouldn't
and for women the default is i
definitely wouldn't sleep with him
unless there's some extraordinary reason
why i should so we sort of start from
different positions it's it's not
exactly accurate but i think it gets at
this intuition that guys are just less
picky at least when it comes to sex with
relationships it's a little different
but for women um
much more selective again because of
because of that risk of pregnancy and so
on that they they tend to carry
[Music]